converting John I'm going to comic-con
but we need to talk and maybe we should
have been talking about this for a while
and I know it's not super fun but the
Internet has become like a less a less
kind place it's unpleasant to admit as a
person who really loves the Internet but
it would appear that we've entered into
a bit of an age of outrage there's not a
problem with humans or with the Internet
it's a problem of humans mixed with the
Internet I think that we'd all kind of
like to talk as much as we're listen to
- which works if it's a two-person
conversation like one person talks the
other person talks 50/50 split is a
pretty good thing and I think we've all
felt this with like a six or eight
person conversation that it can get a
little frustrating when you can't get a
word in edgewise because you're just not
the loudest or most eloquent person in
the room in a billion person
conversation and yeah I'm in San Diego
now cuz I had to get on my plane it's
more like just a deafening roar
accompanied by feelings of powerlessness
I think we are in the first age of the
social Internet and the job of that age
is to suck us in and capture our
eyeballs and keep them as close to those
revenue generating advertisements as
possible research has shown that even
over cute things or inspirational things
or amazing things angering things things
that outraged us that's what our brains
on average are most prone to sharing
problem is whether it makes us angry
definitely matter as to whether we share
it whether it's true or not whether it's
productive or not not really affect or
maybe we need to enter a new stage of
the social internet one where we choose
and we create places on the internet
that aren't just addictive or
distracting but instead bring personal
and societal satisfaction throughout our
lives we know this we have to work to
keep ourselves healthy and to keep our
relationships healthy and to keep our
communities healthy and the Internet is
a huge part of our communities now and a
lot of it is unhealthy these things
don't take care of themselves and we had
this idea early on that they would but
the land in my city is not responsible
for the well-being of the community that
exists on top of it keeping that
community healthy at the top of the
government and the citizens and so
keeping internet communities healthy is
the job of the leaders of those
communities whether they're the owners
or the people working for those
communities or the leaders in those
communities and also the citizens of
those communities without conscious
leadership these communities decay
and they destroy themselves and they
bleach out into the real world where
they harm actual individual humans and
our culture I'd linked to a couple
videos in the description that helped me
think about this stuff well if you want
to watch some other perspectives on it
I've been so inspired by seeing the
positive effects of the plussing that
we've been doing I mean the best
comments are content themselves they add
instead of just react so I've been
loving it both are some people who have
pointed out problems with blessing
particularly that it makes discussion
more difficult when it's in a sea of
pluses those people a nerdfighter named
Melvin created a Chrome extension that
will remove the plus comments from
YouTube comments so that's Thank You
Melvin have always been proud of this
community I have always known that it's
composed almost entirely of kind
thoughtful people I know that because of
the comments section I know that because
I've met so many of you in the real
world I know because at VidCon this year
we have volunteers going around and
giving these wristbands to anyone who
would donate to help the families and
the victims of the pulse nightclub shoot
and then VidCon and universal talent
agency and YouTube all matched those
donations until we raised almost $40,000
and we actually have some left over so
if you want to continue supporting that
effort you can go to dftba.com where
there for sale for five dollars in the
end in a world of infinite content when
shareability is king sometimes kindness
and empathy don't play particularly well
and so we start to forget that they
exist but I do think that we're gonna
start heading into a new age of the
social Internet and it's not gonna
happen immediately or anything where
platforms and the users of those
platforms work together to actually
promote good community and kindness and
empathy and that's certainly happening
in certain corners of the internet and
very proud that it's happening right
here John I'll see you on Tuesday